[Music]
commingo on FYI following our
investigation into the rising number of
kids who Vape the government reacts
[Music]
and we hit the dance floor with one of
the UK's youngest DJs hi I'm Betty also
known as DJ sunshine and I love music
[Music]
welcome to FYI where we got our heads
around the latest news and where you get
to report on your own stories so later
an FYI News Club member chats the stars
of the new Super Mario Brothers movie
and we ask an expert about the Muslim
Festival of Ramadan but first the FYI
team has been looking into why so many
people our age and younger have started
taking up these they're called Vapes or
e-cigarettes and we wanted to do this
because let's be honest we all probably
know someone who uses them but is yet a
big deal well they shouldn't be sold to
anyone under the age of 18 because they
can contain highly addictive nicotine
they were created to help adults stop
smoking tobacco cigarettes but Health
experts have warned that it can be very
damaging to your health we found a lot
of Vape packaging that looks like sweets
with flavors that can be very appealing
to young people the latest figures show
that 1 in 10 11 to 15 year olds are
using Vapes in our last episode of FYI
we investigated why kids are vaping and
what damage it can do it hits some of
the news headlines here's what some
young vapers told us
the main reason why I Vape is not the
feeling it's not the flavor it's the
tricks that's what you see on social
media as well so when you say tricks do
you mean like making shapes of the with
the smoke yeah yeah it's almost like I'm
doing it to look cool
and no one admits that but I will it's
to look cool that's what all the kids
are doing it for how do you get hold of
them because obviously you're not 18 how
do you get hold of The Vape products so
there are some shops that do sell to
under 18s and I get them off quite a lot
of my friends like my friends they'll be
doing it in school and the toilets and
stuff like that and they can't go a day
without doing it
while more research needs to be done
this is the warning we got from one of
the UK's leading doctors for children
about how damaging vaping can be there
are major health problems including
nicotine addiction so if you start
vaping
there is a risk a small risk but a
definite risk that you can get a very
serious lung disease people have gone
into intensive care units gone on hot
bypass machines because of acute
exposure to vaping you know some people
I know they Vape but they're not 100
sure what it does to you in the long
term could you please explain what some
of those risks may be in the long term
we just don't know it's an unknown it
took 30 years to prove that smoking
cigarettes cause lung cancer we don't
want to sit on our hands while another
Fiasco like that develops even the
association that represents the UK
vaping industry told us they had
repeatedly asked the government for
stricter regulations to stop children
buying Vapes because we're a trade body
and we don't have any enforcement Powers
we really are reliant on the government
to look at the current regulations and
put some sensible changes in place that
we've suggested that would solve a lot
of the problem shortly after our
investigation was shown on Sky News and
sky kids the government announced new
measures
[Music]
they announced the creation of a vape
Crackdown Squad the squad's officers
will have the power to remove Vape
products from shops that clearly appeal
to children and an investigation will be
launched to look into ways to stop
underage vaping
[Music]
and more importantly in a statement the
government acknowledged its concerns for
the rising young people vaping you can
still see our special episode FYI
investigates kids who Vape on Sky Kids
On Demand and Via our webpage first.news
forward slash FYI
so you can either report on your own
stories on this show like here's FYI if
you are better also known as DJ Sunshine
she's one of the youngest DJs in the
country
[Music]
hi I'm Bessie also known as DJ sunshine
and I love music DJ
boy
I like pop music and electronic
I like listening to music and my dad
thought that he would like to teach me
to DJ
[Music]
I like how the music goes together and I
also like it how it excites me I think
she's a natural and she's just amazing
at it there's no two words just amazing
she's a very good DJ and I reckon she
could possibly do this when she's older
we're having tons of fun and DJ
Sunshine's so good my teacher in year
two said to me that I could DJ to the
class every Friday in like my friends
always talk to me about at school and
then whenever they hear me DJ they start
dancing and having fun we're having a
really fun time all dancing and watching
her I put Sleepless through everyone in
my Village doors and about 100 people
came to join my live stream
it was exciting and I was really nervous
I look up to Fatboy Slim I like his
music and I like that his daughter
always joins him he says about me
because when I DJ in front of a painting
of him
when I sent her an Instagram Fatboy Slim
liked it
I thought that it was exciting and I
didn't know what to say I think she's
hoping to go to space and DJ on the moon
I want to be an astronaut and a
scientist so I want to be the first DJ's
face it just shows that kids can do
everything I think I'll take it further
in a way than I'll be famous
[Music]
so don't forget if you have a story or
want to report for FYI you can just get
your school to set up an FYI News Club
you can watch and discuss the latest
episodes of free resources and have your
say on FYI or even report for us just
head to our webpage at first.news
forward slash FYI for more details
so why has tiktok been fined a whopping
12.7 million pounds by authorities
well we looked into this and it's for
failing to protect children's privacy
when they use the app yeah the
information commissioner's office which
is in charge of making sure all social
media platforms follow the rules said
that Tick-Tock wrote the law by
processing personal information of
children under the age of 13 without
asking for their parents permission but
this exposed an even bigger issue you're
not even supposed to have an account if
you're under the age of 13 but Tick Tock
allowed 1.4 million people under the age
of 13 to have an account a Tick-Tock
statement said that they had invested
heavily to stop under 13s using the app
in other news that core I the U.S
President Joe Biden paid a visit to
Northern Ireland it was to Mark 25 years
of Peace because of what's known as The
Good Friday agreement which America
helped to negotiate it brought peace to
Northern Ireland after Decades of
conflict today
I come to Belfast to pledge to all the
people of Northern Ireland
the United States of America will
continue
to be your partner in building the
future
the young people of our world deserve
well so when it became separated from
the rest of Ireland in the 1920s and
Northern Ireland became the UK's
smallest Nation
the tension was between unionists who
are happy to remain part of the UK and
nationalists or Republicans who wanted
to be part of Ireland unionists were
mostly Protestant and nationalists were
mostly Catholic and in some areas the
communities were separated by a security
wall The Good Friday agreement involves
politicians representing All Views
sharing power but there are still
tensions and Northern Ireland is on high
alert for a possible terror attack
[Music]
so Braden you have a sweet tooth right
yeah I like chocolate biscuits and I do
like strawberry flavored sweets so what
about 3D printed cheesecake that's gotta
be fake right well check this out
[Music]
it's fact
a team of Engineers at Columbia
University in New York used a 3D printer
to make a cheesecake using edible food
ink as part of a printed food project
cool well a bit of a step up from Cake
check out this 3D printed rocket it's
the world's best 3D printed rocket which
made its launch debut in Florida's Cape
Canaveral Space Center but unfortunately
it failed just three minutes into the
flight and crashed into the Atlantic
up
[Music]
so am I even get into video games kind
of my brothers used to force me to play
them when we were kids well I love him
and I feel like sometimes when your
favorite video game characters get
turned into a film it doesn't always
work but what about the new Super Mario
Brothers when we send FY news club
member Olivia to check it out
the Super Mario Bros film is about two
plumbers Mario and his brother Luigi who
find themselves transported through a
strange pipe into a magical Mushroom
Kingdom
but they get separated what is this
place
I got the chance to interview any Attila
Joy who is Princess Peach the ruler of
the Mushroom Kingdom
[Music]
you never got it
ever ever wow so do you think you will
one day or probably because I think it's
getting like split ends and stuff so
it's just honestly a trim's not that bad
I promise that's the same I have to do
that so do you see any elements of
yourself in Princess Peach gosh I think
there are things that I I hope I am I
hope I'm tough and loving and loyal if
you can finish this you're coming with
me watch and learn
do you find any elements of voice acting
easier than film acting I actually find
it harder so you're projecting your
voice a lot when you are doing voice
acting and it's all that you have and so
if you do a five hour stint of just
screaming essentially by the end of it
you're like where am I what happened
what's going on it's just so cool to be
in a movie with so many of my heroes
specifically Jack Black who's just such
a big deal for me and getting to watch
them work it's so inspiring and I
learned a lot it's amazing thank you
you're welcome have a great day thank
you lovely
fun
and it was really exciting
[Music]
it's currently Ramadan a holy month in
the Islamic faith when Muslims don't eat
or drink from dawn until sunset which is
called fasting it's a super important
time for Muslims all around the world
and not everyone knows loads about it
so we decided to call in an expert to
find out more
[Music]
subramedy is one of Britain's youngest
imams which is a faith leader and he
uses social media to teach us about
Islam he's joining us now so what is
Ramadan all about so ramzan is the
holiest month in the year for Muslims
all over the world it's a month of
fasting So within Islam there are five
pillars and one of the pillars instructs
Muslims to fast for that one month to
work on their spirituality and work on
their betterment to become better people
throughout the year so why do you fast I
mean surely it's really difficult Amazon
and fasting are compulsory for those
people who are fit and able for example
children aren't required to fast people
who are sick people who are traveling
and they're elderly so actually it's
really for the adults and actually it's
a time for us to work on our
spirituality grow as individuals be kind
it's time for us to be kind to our
neighbors not be rude not get angry so
it's more than having not no food and
drink so you said it lasts for about a
month what happens at the end of that
month
so at the end of Amazon it's an event
which over a billion Muslims across the
world are excited for it's the Eid
celebration and the Eid celebration
gives Muslims the opportunity to thank
God for giving us the opportunity to
fast and work on our spirituality so
Muslims go in the morning to the mosque
they exchange presents and it's a really
exciting time not only for children but
for adults as well because you pray
families come together you have loads of
food but also not forgetting that the
purpose of Eid is to thank God for the
opportunity of giving us the fast now an
interesting one is loads of viewers that
watch FYI
Muslim festivals do you think that
should happen in the UK
do you know there are so many religions
in the world like I think if one
Community was given the holiday it'd be
unfair on the rest and also we don't
live in a Muslim country so we don't
expect a holiday well thanks so much for
joining us Sabra it's been wonderful
speaking to you thanks for having me no
it's not just Ramadan I need that are
being celebrated due to Mark in the
Passover and it's been one of the most
important times of the year for
Christians Easter now we're going to
leave you guys with some images coming
in from across the globe see you next
time bye
foreign
[Music]